but this is America in shutdown day 22
it was just a few weeks ago that we were
hearing very scary numbers like these
the number was 2.2 million people would
have died 2.2 million people would have
died in a short period of time but as
you saw on that slide that was our real
number about a hundred thousand to two
hundred thousand and we think that that
is the range we're the likelihood that
there will be a hundred thousand
Americans who die from this virus the
answer is yes we need as sobering a
number as that is we should be prepared
for it but now it looks like those
projections which drove the experts to
recommend an aggressive economic
shutdown of America were wildly off base
the head of the Centers for Disease
Control now says US coronavirus deaths
could be in his words much lower than
the hundred thousand or 240,000
predicted by some earlier models every
model is only as good as the assumptions
that go into it originally the
assumptions were that fewer Americans
would keep their distance but you all
behave so things are better now
understand what we're talking about here
the final death count today is projected
to be about 80,000 people in other words
30 times fewer than the high end of what
was originally forecast that 2.2 million
figure and three times fewer than the
240,000 number now we know that our
country is still experiencing
excruciating loss a loss of life and we
believe as we've said every night that
every life is precious every death
matters to every family due to whatever
caused but it is worth asking is it not
what would our response have been and
what our response have been less
damaging to the economy into the lives
of all of you millions of Americans if
we had had more accurate models from the
start and shouldn't this experience make
us less willing to rely on the same
experts to help determine when and how
we should reopen our economy meanwhile
in Europe the leaders of Norway
mark check Republican Austria have
announced plans to relax coronavirus
lockdown restrictions Norway will end
its ban on families traveling to their
holiday cottage cottages on April 20th
other businesses will be allowed to
reopen then to Denmark well they'll
press ahead with a cautious reopening
beginning with daycare and primary
schools on April 15th and talks are
underway to get their businesses up and
running again as well and more good news
from Germany which has the third largest
outbreak in Europe they saw the number
of daily recoveries outnumber new kovat
cases for the first time on Tuesday
check out their new infections curve
looking much better but in France the
government there has decided to take
away the one thing people had left to
keep them frankly sane by deciding to
ban outdoor daytime exercise now that
seems totally nuts to me I'm not an
expert in these things but exercise has
so many health benefits that would seem
to outweigh the risk that you're gonna
get coronavirus when you run or bike
past someone on a trail although
thinking about I don't know if the
physical exertion even indoors can pose
its own challenges
[Music]
and finally you feel it don't you that
America is getting increasingly anxious
about this shutdown and given the fact
that the death rate for kovat 19 may end
up being only slightly worse than a very
tough flu season we want answers we want
objective metrics for restarting things
back to this idea of reopening up the
economy so it's not like there's a
switch that you can just turn it back on
how does the administration envision
this happening our first mission is to
save lives but there is a dual track
that the president has already initiated
some of the best minds here at the White
House are beginning to think about what
recommendations will look like that we
that we give to businesses that we give
to States
well little vague but what about parents
and their children well they're ever
gonna go back to school what do you
think summer camp holds and what do you
think the start of next school year
holds it is unpredictable but you can
get a feel for if we start talking about
the things where the curve goes down and
we really have minimal how we respond
and what kind of a rebound we see or
don't see you know what else is going
like this retention of information kids
learning that's a lot of parents that
you're emailing me and thank you keep
the emails coming but those answers are
murky right they don't give you a sense
of okay what are we looking at here
remember as much as we respect and
admire all those who are on the front
lines of our health care system
especially doctors nurses all the staff
we didn't vote for doctors we didn't
vote for modelers or statisticians it's
brilliant as many of them can be we
voted for political leadership that sees
the big picture that means the whole
picture of America because we all know
we walk out the front door life entails
risks the vulnerable need protection
especially the elderly and those with
underlying conditions and yet at the
same time freedom needs preserving we
just
have our people denied the ability to
make a living go to school attend
worship services travel as they wish see
their friends we need realistic
objective metrics we need clear
protocols to give people peace of mind
once we do restart our economy and
reopen again we want people to go back
to restaurants and so forth we want
those businesses to not just survive but
thrive again otherwise we risk creating
a new epidemic one of continuing mass
unemployment depression societal
fallouts even the medical experts today
still can't foresee and those are my
thoughts at the end of day 22 America in
shutdown